but is the holiday season it is and
we're all familiar with these standard
Christmas characters you got your Santa
sure you got the elves yeah reindeer oh
yeah
those are the ones that all the kids
love but there's actually another
character that's been around for
hundreds of years who still has not
caught on isn't really caught on
especially with the kids
he's a real character from German
folklore he probably know him as the
Krampus you've heard of the Krampus
Krampus he's a real character from
German folklore there he is he's a
that's him this is real that's from a
real book he's a demon who comes around
at night show him again snatches up
naughty children and stuffs them in his
basket right so he can eat them later on
right yeah I wonder why he never caught
on
well anyway apparently we found out the
Krampus is tired of being hated he and
he has a very good PR team out here in
Los Angeles are making some changes to
soften his image
we got a call and he wanted to come here
tonight to show us the new Krampus
please welcome the Krampus let's get him
in here
[Applause]
thank you thank you tolling and thank
you very much hey I appreciate the
opportunity to state my case yes I've
been labeled a monster for centuries but
these days people are noticing that as
monsters go
Krampus ain't looking so bad okay now
Krampus tell us what do you mean by that
well let me put it this way who'd you
have to be alone in a hotel room with me
oh this guy no okay yeah I know who
would you rather have your tween
daughter meet at the mall
silly old Krampus oh this good old boy
okay yeah all right well Krampus I see
what you're all see what you're getting
at but none of the changes none of what
you just said changes the fact that you
were a demon who kidnaps people during
the holidays and if I'm not mistaken
eats them okay
yes that is something I do so sue me I
have my own holiday tradition but look I
never said eating children is for
everyone until now it's time
hey let's get right to it it looks like
we have everything we need except for
the main ingredient of course Kelly do
you have it this is my assistant Kelly
wait wait wait a minute wait who then
tell us applauding wait a minute no
krampus stop you were not gonna cook a
baby
what of course not I wouldn't dream of
it
Kelly's just bringing the tofu see just
tofu
Oh Kelly simply brought her baby to work
she's a working mother do you have a
problem with working mom no okay I'm
really sorry Krampus I misunderstood I
apologize good answer now for the sake
of time dick I've prepared the dish in
advance okay here it is Oh
oh there we that is terrific what is
that grant is my signature casserole oh
my god it looks delicious
what's in a Krampus oh it's got tofu
cheese celery fresh peppers baby chow
wait a minute wait a minute you just say
baby
oh of course three cups of baby you
gotta have baby it really makes the dish
now who wants a bite okay nobody
Andy Andy no no wait up I don't want to
be rude no there's a baby no you're not
in there just sit down all right then
more for me it's offering the milk don't
I get a baby anything over that baby
baby the Krampus everyone what [ __ ]
we'll be right back
[Applause]
[Music]
you